*Girls go to college to get more knowledge.
Boys go to Jupiter to get more stupider.*
*distorted TSERIES DISS TRACK*
BOBS OR VEGANA, WHICH EVER WILL IT
Tik Tok - the absolute state of humanity right now.
I did a video last week mentioning that trolls have been starting to appear on Tik Tok.
Making a blank face to a serious topic or making an epic silly dance
while someone says they'd lost their mother and such and so.
*depressed girl: And then when I realized you didn't...*
*I felt so stupid...*
Pewds: OOOHHHH
He did not just hit her with it! (savage 9000%)
Now that has just blown up completely and it's amazing.
bhhahahah
Let's go through some of the epic Tik Tok trolling, guys. Let's just jump into it!
*Grace:: You said you were in love with me.*
*???: I say a lot of things, Grace*
*Grace: But you're in love with me. I know you're in love with me.*
Pewds: Aww, that's so sad.
pfffpf
That's right!
That girl thought some stranger was gonna add in some cute lil
"Oh, I love you."
INSTEAD
He kicked her in the face! That was epic (dab)
Why?
Why!? I still have no answer to my question.
Why do all these kids record this to begin with?
*handsum man: I'd say things are going pretty well for me on here.*
*Thank You, Tik Tok.*
*I'm on the cover of a cringe compilation.*
hehe
I'm moving to LA
To become a famous TikToker
Damn!
The next Logan Paul everybody
We found him!
You know the Paul brothers, people don't know, they started on Vine.
But I think, in a way we should be thankful to Tik Tok,
because Tik Tok saved us from musical.ly
emigrating into YouTube.
It's good that we have it in one spot, so we know where to send the nukes.
I literally want to get out of my body and go somewhere else.
oh no
Guys, I cannot tell you enough how important it is to love yourself.
Love your body and who you are and find that inner strength, and show it.
You can also be beautiful.
What a great message, everybody.
If your abs look like a poor drawing of Peter Griffin:
then that's okay!
In case it wasn't obvious in Tik Tok, you can make a reply.
I don't know what it's called.
It's called something else. But how do you do fellow kids? I don't know what you call it
And that's what led to this Tik Tok trolling.
Sometimes they just push it to the next level like this one.
*we got what we deserve*
So this started with the girl with..
You know A+ for creativity
*and way down we go go go go go*
*way down we go*
Oh my god
Some of the trollings are just bad
I'll say that.
But some of them, damn,  A+
A+
Hi
Take two steps forward if you're amazing
Now you better have taken two steps forward
because you
are wonderful and beautiful and just if..
Does he have a gun behind.. like a knife behind his back?
What is he gonna do?
I don't trust this man.
This reminds me of those vines where the guy just be like
bheheh You so beautiful. Oh my god.
AH!
So to all those who think I was just bluffing about telling the kids parents.
I wasn't. I actually sent them a message
Telling their parents what their kids are doing.
Oh snap
They're onto us.
There's his mother as well.
It's amazing
So I need to know something, why do girls these days have to dress half-naked?
I mean, didn't your mama teach you to cover up your breasts?
Girls, keep it classy not trashy!
You can't get a good man any other way.
Why are moms using Tik Tok?
Why is anyone using Tik Tok?
Speaking of Tik Tok?
Here's a Tik Tok ad!
That's right everybody! You make a video about Tik Tok
Tik Tok... advertisement through Google has just been like
We gonna pull an ad on that
It doesn't matter if you're making fun of it
Or if you're trash-talking it.
Put a Tik Tok ad in there.
Every tweet I got from last video was this like
I got a Tik Tok ad on this video
You know what? Maybe I can cheat the system.
What if I just..
I want to get those premium ads, right?
What if I just start saying like?
expensive car
Incredible jewelry
I just bought a rolex and so should you
Buy an expensive watch
expensive
luxurious
INCREDIBLE RICHNESS
WATCHES AND CARS
Hopefully you got an amazing ad there
If it's not a premium ad. I'm gonna be so disappointed.
Oh my god. I love these
the ones that are just
heh
Like what's the original video?
It's just some kid making it rhyme
*get my knowledge both go to Jupiter to get more stupider*
She did not just say they go to Jupiter to get more stupider!
??????
*If you don't like furries go away. If you don't like furries go away*
*I've got a lot to do not any time for you if you don't like furries go*
*away*
*now*
I'm not going anywhere
Cause no animal can tell me what to do.
You know what I eat for breakfast?
dogs
You guys want to see a magic trick?
I'm gonna pull this out of my hat really quick
Gotcha..mhemhhe
Oh my god, is this again?
*now lets both go to Jupiter to get more stupider*
Can we just have a..
Thank you Brad 2 for editing out all the copyrighted material of this video
Appreciation. Thank you. Brad 2.
Is it cool if I bring my sister? No, dude, it's bro time
Yeah, she can come
If only my friend's sister looked that attractive when I was younger.
goddamnit
it's not fair
Wearing  like a jeans corset or what?
What even is that?
* If you don't like furries go away*
*If you don't like furries go away*
*I've got a lot to do and not any time for you. if you don't like furries*
*go*
*away*
*now*
This is so sad
*Girls go to college to get more knowledge*
*boys go to Jupiter to get more stupider*
How long is it gonna go on?
*I'm a new soul, I came to this strange world
Hoping I could learn a bit 'bout how to give and take*
He's gonna tug her!
It's the tugging one
OOhhhh
OH
WHAT?
oh
I love this
Oh! It's supposed to be like you're making out with her.
Oh my god
Why do they do that?
That's an epic very quick rubric solving win
Good job.
So parents have started to notice this how..
Kids are just making fun of kids on this site.
And of course the response is..
I think there needs to be a parental contact on Tik Tok
Because obviously some of these parents don't know what their 10 year olds are doing.
And, I mean, some of these screen names
Thot 69? What's a thot?
She must be trolling.
I don't believe that
You don't just go: "Thot 69. What's a thot?"
"What the frick guys? I was..."
So you guys..
SO YOU GUYS IF WANT A SHOUT OUT YOU JUST NEED TO DO A DUET WITH ME AND I SHOT YOU OUT
What is happening?
I feel so old
I never felt this old as when I look at these Tik Tok videos
You know I thought it would just be one trend with the..
*good boys like bad guys*
*a dadadadaa*
already
And I thought we would be done
But it just keeps going
And it's epically
Tik Tok! I love it
You know what?
I never thought I would say that
I actually never thought I would say that
If you are under the age of 18 years old
Do not get on my profile
Do not do duets with my profile videos
Do not even look at my profile.
Keep moving.
Why are you a over 18 and on Tik Tok?
That's the appropriate question here
All right more for dancing after 40. This is the fortnite hike dance
I'm gonna turn sideways so you can see
You're gonna kick your leg
You're gonna pump your arm
And then you're gonna move it down low
Ready?
Don't let kids intimidate you
That's the thing
Why are all these adults on there?
I'm stuck in between these kids and these adults?
What am I?
What am I supposed to be?
Where do I belong fellow kids and adults?
Guys
Comment Thanos if you made it to the end
These kids must be..
STOPPED
and adults as well
Thank you very much
I hope this a .. Tik Tok cringe thing keeps going
God bless everyone.
I'm PewDiePie
Brofist out